Se confirmó una respuesta que se
esperaba hace mucho el destino
profesional de linda Caicedo la estelar
juvenil colombiana cumplió el miércoles
los 18 años reglamentarios para firmar
firmar en Europa y el viernes será
presentada por todo lo alto por el Real
Madrid después de meses en los que linda
se debatía entre ofertas europeas y
también de la liga estadounidense para
Qué significa este fichaje para el
fútbol femenino de Sudamérica es muy
importante es importantísimo Yo creo que
por tres razones la primera porque
siempre que hablemos de fútbol femenino
estamos hablando de un montón de mujeres
que Ya jugaron fútbol pero que nunca
habían tenido la visibilidad que están
teniendo las jugadoras hoy en día es
decir que se habla de una lucha de un
reconocimiento de muchos años para que
esto esté pasando entonces hablamos en
Colombia de un montón de pioneras como
Liliana Zapata
como bueno Miriam Guerrero la primera
entrenadora de la selección Colombia que
nunca digamos tuvo este tipo de
visibilidad pero son muchas mujeres que
construyeron el fútbol femenino lo que
es hoy en día en lugar por linda Caicedo
por lo que ella representa como jugadora
es una jugadora excepcional una jugadora
que desde los 15 años demostró que tiene
unas características fuera de lo común
una jugadora que además en el Club Atlas
también fundado por una exjugadora de la
selección Colombia como Carolina Pineda
encontró esa formación necesaria para
llegar a este tipo de nivel y lo que
vimos el año pasado participando en la
sub-17 sub-20 y en la selección de
mayores la hace una jugadora excepcional
ahora es relevante para el fútbol
sudamericano y también para el fútbol
español porque recordemos que sólo hasta
el 2020 el Real Madrid decidió meterse
en el fútbol femenino el hecho de que
ellos apuesten en este punto por un
fichaje de este nivel en el que ya va a
haber una remuneración digamos
interesante desde el punto de vista del
mercado lo que hace es demostrar que el
fútbol femenino logró tener un impacto
significativo deportiva
institucionalmente para que esto esté
pasando y creo que el fichaje de linda
que hizo además con característica que
tiene el colombiano de ser muy hincha de
sus jugadores va a hacer que en términos
de mercadeo sea un punto muy interesante
este año además Pues linda tiene el
mundial el mundial femenino Australia
Nueva Zelanda donde tendrá que ratificar
esto yo creo que el Real Madrid si bien
no es un equipo como el Barcelona que
desde el 2002 apostó por por el fútbol
femenino creo que en este momento está
intentando ponerse a ritmo y va a ser
interesante para ella